Miranda Sings Miranda Sings yeah so
what the [__] is happening with this
girl like I think we need to educate
people on who she is it might be a lot
yeah I mean she's featured in Seinfeld's
comedians of cars yeah he did an episode
he went on her show she's basically his
Seinfeld's most watched episode
apparently really wow that is crazy so
Colleen Ballinger is a internet
influencer YouTube YouTuber internet
celebrity and basically got famous
making like song parodies where she
would like wear this crazy makeup play
this character Miranda Sings and would
sing like terrible covers of songs and
that was like her character and she was
like this wacky person and then she kids
loved it kids loved it like her demo is
probably like eight to like 15 something
like that and then she kind of pivoted
to just being like a YouTuber I had a
kid blah blah and this happened in 2020
this kid that was basically running her
fan account was posting a bunch of stuff
now they came out in 2020 all this
happened in like 2013 or 2014 when the
kid was like 13 14 years old and
basically she just starts like confiding
him like really personal things about
like her divorce she starts telling him
all of like these really like personal
secrets because they built a
relationship through him running her fan
account they ended up like meeting up a
few times like going to dinner yada yada
and then the whole big thing is that
like she sent him lingerie that was like
the big controversy that everyone's
looking at I looked into it it's not as
crazy as it sounds even though it's
still inappropriate basically they did
like a lingerie reveal on one of her
like live streams where her husband wore
the lingerie over his clothes
and then he was commenting like oh this
is so funny blah blah like I let me have
it or something like that and then she
basically sent him the lingerie how old
is he I think at this time he was like
15 or 16. something like that and then
so she sent it to him and his parents
were like what the hell like he lives in
Dublin they were just like what the [__]
this is insane super inappropriate they
told him to cut off contact took all the
stuff from him I think other things
transpired like in their interpersonal
relationship I think she was asking
about like
pointed personal questions about like
virginity and stuff like that I don't
know the exact details but it's wild
though like it's basically like having
very personal conversations with like
her underage fans and then also sending
them like sexual clothing even though it
wasn't in the most sexual way it's still
crossing the line so he basically
pointed this out in 2020 and then it
resurfaced now I don't really know
exactly why but uh it seems like it
comes up like every year or so and then
this one really popped off because she
wrote like an apology not apology video
where she sang yeah her non-apology
and that got people fired up too I saw
that that was good yeah this was good
you like the like I mean yeah some bars
in it but like I I I'm curious like you
thought it was like a smart PR move or
the song was good like I didn't watch it
oh no I just like the fact that she was
kind of like
singing some bars and then talking
singing some bars I've never seen her
before I didn't maybe she does this all
the time and I was like oh I was pretty
impressive but outside of that I think
she's a little weird for engaging with
young kids yeah so much because I did a
little research there was like a group
chat where she had like a bunch of
younger people in it I thought I read
this yeah and so it's like and then she
fired that kid who was yeah one why do
you have a such a young kid running your
social media he started it on his own I
think I read she was like talking to
them about her relationships and her
issues and it's like and then she fired
him for posting something inappropriate
even though she had okayed the post
which I'm like that's [__] up
but um yeah she just sounds a little off
she sounds like she's on Spectrum a
little bit but she doesn't realize that
she does things that are a bit
inappropriate until it comes back up and
the butter in the ass yeah do you know
more because no that's the extent of my
knowledge did I miss anything on that
models do you know anything else uh no I
mean she had some like later on things
with like Trisha Paytas and like they
had a show and how long ago did you stop
running her fan account
weeks literally weeks ago no did you
watch this lady like were you no no I
never did I just caught up on it with
Phil DeFranco he explained everything
pretty well yeah but the song's wild she
opens going they told me not to talk
about this but they didn't tell me not
to sing about it yeah that's sort of
funny that sounds like some shelter
right
it's like everybody tells you hey don't
talk about this oh so guys
but yeah so I don't it just seems
inappropriate I don't know if it's like
I don't know if she's like grooming like
those are like the the accusations on
her I don't know how you can really
prove that I don't know if she had
intent to like do sexual behaviors with
these kids maybe she did I have no idea
ain't nobody want to [__] your kid yo
well ain't nobody want to [__] your kid
I mean tell these parents nobody wants
have you seen To Catch a Predator
no
they made 10 seasons
how many women were on that show I was
in Campbell there's a handful no yeah
there's no [__]
were there [__] yeah I think I think
like famously there's like a couple find
a [__] for him to catch a predator I'm
looking I'm looking thank you
um
foreign
get out of here bro yeah this she's huge
like I didn't realize how big she was
in terms of following oh dude maybe he
caught no female predators
yeah come on I don't think there was
come on come on Chelsea knows his
Predator
what about all these female teachers who
[__] the students
she's not a teacher bro she an artist
hey ain't none of these artists want to
[__] your kids parents
I mean she's a goof for sending the
lingerie to a 15 year old like you're
just an idiot because you should be
thinking like oh this could potentially
go wrong she says it in the live stream
so literally like the kids talking he's
like oh let me have it like send it to
me or like oh I something to the effect
of that he expressed interest in it and
then she basically was like oh yeah
we're definitely gonna send it too it's
gonna be so funny we're gonna send so
his parents are probably gonna be like
oh my gosh why is this girl sending my
kid lingerie whatever and then send it
to him oh like in the moment she's even
recognizing how crazy it is and it still
did it so this is ridiculous this whole
thing is ridiculous she also shouldn't
be confiding personal information to
children
it's not sexual I don't think but it's
just weird like why are you
man bro I'm hanging with my nephews I
don't know how many times I ask him so
what's school like every question is
what is school like bro you got friends
at school what's school about and that's
the whole conversation every day and
it's constant just being like yeah that
sounds crazy because you're just like
you know if she was doing this on Twitch
it'd be totally okay
and she was just on Twitch confiding
whatever the [__] she was confiding yeah
and it would be the same age people
watching you can tell everyone you can't
tell anyone yeah how many people are in
that group chat oh I don't know the
exact amount I don't think it was a lot
I think there's like a handful of like
what was inappropriate that she was
confiding him the Trisha paid his photos
this one thing that people bring up so
Trish Paytas has and only fans and uh
apparently she was sharing
the photos from the only fans of
treasure potatoes in a group chat that
had miners in it and like in a mocking
way how what were the photos uh I don't
know I died was it nude photos was it
photos of you know her dog like not a
worse kind of thought it says adult
content don't surface that's
pornographic bruh yo what really
happened to y'all y'all guys
no
you're really wrong for that one y'all
are crazy bro so it's surfing I felt
less insecure as it went off because
when you started I was like am I crazy
yeah wait wait
wait wait
we gonna see you keep the same energy
you guys are just in a position where
you know your wife isn't gonna do that
[__]